Aaron Carter's ex sharing intimate
photos of the late singer with his baby
boy I just want to be the best at what I
do on Tuesday Aaron's one-time fiance
Melanie Martin posts a touching tribute
as their son Prince celebrated his first
birthday
[Music]
next to rare pics of Aaron with his
little one Melanie writes quote today is
going to be a tough one for me but I
know your daddy is playing birthday
songs for you up in heaven I love making
music it's definitely my happy place on
her Instagram story Melanie's scene with
Prince at his birthday party
[Music]
and in one video the mom says she has to
be strong for their son
this comes over two weeks after Aaron
was found dead at his California home
for now no cause of death has been
revealed what I need is people to
understand that I'm human
and I make mistakes just like every
other human in this world Melanie and
Aaron's relationship was on again off
again following his death she called him
a wonderful man who loved to take care
of his family when I got there
the day the incident happened
there was no friends that was there
I was really surprised it was just me
and Melanie she's in a lot of pain
a lot of pain in the statement to E.T
Melanie said quote Aaron never gave up
on me we might have had arguments and
breakups but we really could not live
without each other
following his child star days Aaron
struggled with addiction and his mental
health are you still sober what kind of
Journey are you on now or what I smoke
weed I mean there I have anxiety
problems I take medication for anxiety
like I mean it's just it's just what it
is you know in the wake of Aaron's death
we learned the former pop star had
recently missed a therapy appointment
and that he'd been previously advised by
his attorney to make a will but it was
not completed before he died and the L.A
County Fire Department confirmed to E.T
a welfare check was made for Aaron on
September 20th it's just you know I went
through some hard times some difficult
things Melanie's also taken to Times
Square in New York City with a public
tribute
[Music]
on the billboard photos of Prince and
his late father quote Aaron Carter in
remembrance from your fans and
supporters
[Music]